Fredy Rodan hey David how would you
increase voter turnout in the United
States without making voting mandatory I
think this is an interesting one there
are countries that have very high voter
turnout because voting is mandatory my
home birth country of Argentina is such
an example a big reason why I don't
renew my Argentinean passport is that as
an adult from what I'm told I would have
to justify why I'm not voting when there
is an election and of course I would say
I don't live there and I'm not really
following the local politics but I would
have to do that because voting is
mandatory and I don't really want to do
that so I think there's a couple
different things we could do to increase
voter turnout without making voting
mandatory number one a lot of people
don't vote because elections are just
not competitive in many cases there's
tons of elections that are unopposed by
an incumbent in many cases or on an
unopposed because that an incumbent is
retiring and there's only one person
running for it that decreases voter
turnout that relates to the fact that we
often don't have that that relates to a
lot of problems including the two-party
duopoly and that third parties would
also potentially help to increase voter
turnout voter suppression is also
something that influences voting if it
were easier to vote if you didn't have
more and more restrictive voting hours
and the requirement to go get supposedly
free voter IDs that actually require you
to have other documents that aren't free
to get right all of the voter
suppression stuff that the right has
Republican Republican z-- have
deliberately been doing to hold down the
non-white and disproportionately
Democratic vote that would increase
voter turnout as well but I do think
that at its core people need to believe
that their vote matters in order to get
them to vote more often and matters
doesn't mean there's two ways we can
interpret my vote matters right there's
the sort of caricature which is most
elections don't come down to one vote so
my vote doesn't matter now that's sort
of logically fallacious because if
everybody that that occurred to ya voted
then yes your individual vote might not
change the results but collectively the
votes of everyone who questions the
value of their vote could actually
change the results so that's layer one
but I actually mean something else when
I say people
they feel their vote doesn't matter
there's a lot of people who are saying
my vote doesn't matter because in the
end no matter who wins nothing really is
going to change and that's I think a
deeper issue and it relates to third
parties and it relates to a lot of other
problems with the electoral system the
idea that elections don't come down to
one vote to me always came across as a
little bit arrogant you know to
rationalize that as then I shouldn't
vote because you do live in a community
you live in a society where we're
picking the leaders of all of us right
so the idea that it should not only
change on you if you're not the decider
then you don't care to vote type of
thing yeah it's a little arrogant in a
way but I mean there are plenty of ways
to increase political participation one
would be for to move election days from
Tuesday's to the weekends because people
got to work right and if you feel as if
that your vote doesn't matter
a great way to make it matter more is to
do a Instant Runoff system Instant
Runoff voting or ranked choice voting I
think they're the exact same thing
although maybe there's a slight
difference between the two but generally
it's the idea that you can say really
who I want to win is this candidate if
after the first round of voting is done
they are not viable then switch my vote
to this other candidate and I think that
that would also interest a lot of people
for sure so those are a few of the
things that can be done but big picture
there's also a low level of engagement
with the political system for a lot of
people a lot of people just feel like
the system we have of voting is not one
that ultimately makes a difference to
them to their lives and that's something
more systemic that you've got to address
what's interesting is on the
presidential level if you have two
candidates who are not interesting
enough people won't really care out I
care enough to go vote for them Yeah
right
but if then if they're too interesting
then there's all these controversies and
scandals that go along with it like this
last round Hillary versus Trump right
I'm available just because of a
caricature and that will negatively
affect voter turnout as well yes it's
it's bad it's bad in either way isn't